[Music]
we have seen 11 siblings growing up in a
chaotic family in the loud house on
Nickelodeon it must be really hard for
the parents to deal with so many people
in the house but what will happen once
they have their own kids make sure you
watch this video until the end to know
what Laurie would look like as a mother
if you love the loud house as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten loud house
characters reimagined as parents Lisa
she might be the second youngest but she
is also the smartest girl of the family
it's incredible for someone to win a
Nobel Prize and she did it when she was
only a toddler and with so many
experiments equations and formulas that
she is working on all the time she can
only get better this is why Lisa will
probably be the best scientist in the
world she was in kindergarten when we
first met her but we bet that she
skipped a couple of grades and got her
doctorate degree at only 14 years old
that wouldn't be too surprising from her
now that she discovered a cure for
cancer and how to travel in time Lisa is
ready for a new challenge she wants to
become a mom but don't think that this
smart girl will ever have time to date
boys and complicated things like that we
think that her little son would probably
be another of her experiments as she
tries to clone herself and here she is
with her son as Cruella De Ville 84 and
Jay boy 32 acts reimagined her they look
so similar to each other that the crazy
experiment theory could totally make
sense no matter what Lisa will always be
here to answer his questions when he
asks why the sky is blue or how to
create a robot smarter than any human
but there is one thing that her son will
teach her the love of a mother is
something that you can't explain
Lola and here is our favorite little
princess of the loud family Lola loves
everything girly including pink dresses
and tiaras
she is really precious and the problem
is that she knows it this is why she
wouldn't mind seeing her 10 siblings
working as her servants princess should
have everything she ever asks for right
it would be hard to imagine her
changing diapers and cleaning the house
but after winning many beauty pageants
as a kid as a teenager and as a young
adult it will be time for her to meet
her prince charming and give birth to a
new beauty queen the loud family can't
lose its title after all and this new
kid will have to fight for it below low
will be surprised to find out that she
isn't expecting a girl but a young boy
just look at how Cruella De Vil 84 and J
boy 32x reimagined them it seems like
being a boy doesn't stop this young man
from wearing a crown and loving the
color pink and with this cute little
face we think that he'll be ready to win
any beauty pageant his mother Lola will
be the best coach to teach him
everything he needs to know about
walking posing and smiling on a runway
and with this perfect look this young
man will meet his princess and see his
fairy tale story come true in no time
Lana the twin sisters don't have a lot
of things in common
I'm like Lola this young girl loves
playing in the mud getting her hands
dirty and fixing things the more
disgusting it is the more interested she
is this is why this tomboy would
probably grow up to be a plumber and
she'll have fun doing it and we think
that this is how she will meet the love
of her life Lana is the kind of girl who
wouldn't mind kissing a frog and finding
out that he is a prince charming that's
because even though she loves things
that are ugly on the outside this young
girl is actually very pretty on the
inside and anyway boys have been looking
for a girl who is not afraid to play
outside for a long time this is why it
won't take too much time for one of
Lana's friends to become her partner in
life the two will also have a beautiful
little baby together
just look at how Cruella De Vil at4 and
J boy 23x reimagined them they look
pretty clean now but it won't take much
time until they both jump in the mud
together and get their hands dirty Lana
will be happy to have someone to play
outside with and her son will grow up
knowing that some things are more
important than looks we have never seen
a prettier little family Lucy with that
dark look not a lot of people would like
to go near her but once you get to know
Lucy you know that this young girl is
actually really
nice she might be a little weird but
that's what makes people unique and we
have to admit that we all feel like her
sometimes Lucy doesn't seem to be really
into boys but don't forget that vampires
are actually really romantic this is why
she will probably meet a young man who
will hate love just as much as she does
the two will be perfect together they
will even have a baby together just look
at how Jay boy 23 ex reimagined her Lucy
still looks like she doesn't care about
anything but she will probably never
admit that she cried a little bit when
her baby was born she took this
opportunity to dress him just like her
so she'll feel like she is not the only
one like that in the world anymore if
he's just like her we bet that this
little boy will be a very quiet baby the
game that they love the most is probably
peekaboo as Lucy can surprise him every
time she appears out of nowhere if you
ever thought that Lucy's heart was cold
it will immediately be warmed up when
she holds her baby in her arms no one
can keep themselves from smiling when
they see this beautiful little face
Lincoln this young boy cares so much
about his sister's that it isn't hard to
imagine him growing up to be an awesome
father it is difficult for him to live
with ten other sisters when he is the
only boy but we know that his family is
what he loves the most in the world no
matter how much he tries to avoid them
we know that he will always be the hero
of these 10 young women we totally
understand why Ronnie and loves him or
we should say loves being his friend
because that's all they are we bet that
they will keep using this as an inside
joke saying that they are not dating
even when they'll be married their
daughter will even join them by saying
that she is not their daughter she is
just their friend just look at them as
sketch toons reimagine them Lincoln
looks really proud to be a father and
Ronnie Ann is really happy to still be
by his side just look at her cooking
waffles for her kid as nelec reimagined
her being a mom totally suits her
growing up with ten sisters we bet that
Lincoln will love to have a big family
and this is why another artist
reimagined him with another baby however
he will realize that taking care of them
takes a lot of time and this is why he
will deserve a good night of sleep Lynne
here comes the best member of the
family at least that's what Lynn wants
us to think because she's the most
competitive this young girl loves to
play sport and always wants to prove
that she is better than her siblings
which can be a little annoying sometimes
but no matter what we love her like that
because we have to admit that she
actually is the best this is why it
would be hard for a guy to ever seduce a
girl like her Blaine is so independent
strong and proud that many guys would
never dare to talk to her but no matter
what we think that she'll find someone
as good as her and they will be able to
compete against each other all the time
but the biggest challenge Lynne will
ever have to face is probably being a
mother just look at how Cruella De Vil
84 and day boy 23 acts reimagined them
her son seems to have just as much
energy as his mother used to have but
this time Lynne will have to learn that
she can't always be the best it's hard
for her to keep up as she is getting
older and this is why she now has a new
mission she is now a coach who will make
sure that the sports team of her son
will be the best and this is how she'll
learn that being better than others is
not important as long as you do your
best
LuAnn when this young lady is here we
know that we'll be hearing another joke
soon her siblings probably heard too
many of them and this is why they don't
laugh anymore but we think that LuAnn is
always hilarious and we are lucky that
we don't live in the loud house because
we are not ready to be the victim of one
of her pranks having a sense of humor is
what most people are looking for when
dating so we bet that it won't take too
much time for this girl to get the
attention of a boy she likes but first
you'll have to impress her by showing
that he is the best audience and
laughing at all of her jokes but if he
really loves her we know that he'll
never stop laughing
Luann's kid will be really lucky to live
in this family just look at how Cruella
De Vil 84 and SP 99 stuff reimagined
them we think that this young boy will
never stop smiling with a mother like
that
and he'll probably make her laugh even
more with all the pranks that he will
pull on his family it's just going to be
crazy in this house and this is what
will make them the best family after all
those who laugh together stay together
and wouldn't it be great to see these
two stand-up comedians on stage we would
certainly love to be watching them
performing together one day
Luna here comes the loudest member of
the family no matter what time of day it
is you can always see Luna performing
with all these hours of practice it is
not surprising that she will one day be
a big star she already got the perfect
look and she is just getting better
every day
when it comes to love we already know
who Luna has in mind it's the beautiful
Sam who is her love interest they looked
so cute together that we hope they'll
never leave each other
wouldn't it be great to see them get
married and start their own family they
would adopt a young baby and they'll be
happier than ever together just look at
how sketch toons reimagine Luna and her
daughter whether it is during the winter
or the summer Luna wants to show her
daughter that she'll always have a
mother by her side however it means that
the artist would have to take a break
from a rockstars career to take care of
her daughter she doesn't want to be on
tour all around the world while her baby
is growing up and taking her first steps
but no matter what it will probably be
the best performance of her career this
little girl will have the chance to hear
the best lullabies when going to bed and
when she grows up she'll probably become
her mother's best inspiration Leni
even if she is the second oldest member
of the loud family we have to admit that
Lennie is a little naive and ditzy but
we can easily forget about it because
she makes up for it by being kind and
beautiful Lennie is the kind of sister
that we would all like to have she is so
easygoing and happy-go-lucky that we
love having her around and this is why
we think that it won't take too much
time for her to find a boyfriend we
already saw that she had a crush on a
boy and we really hope that it works out
between the two falling in love will
probably make her even more naive we
won't mind as long as this is what makes
her happy
we hope that Lennie loved living with a
lot of siblings because she will have a
big family too just look at how new
Locke reimagined her Lennie is more
beautiful than ever even if she has
three kids to deal with don't you think
that those three kids look like Lenny's
younger sisters it will be like the loud
house once again with all these
characters having even more kids it will
be crazy to see them together during
Christmas time and no matter what Lennie
will be there to make everyone smile
Lauri and laugh
but not least is the oldest sister
Laurie it's hard growing up with many
siblings and having to take care of them
because she is the oldest she used to
have all the attention from her parents
and then ten more kids became part of
her family to steal the spotlight this
is why Laurie deserves the chance to be
a little bossy sometimes being the big
sister comes with a lot of
responsibilities and we understand why
she would be taking advantage of it
sometimes but this is also what taught
her how to take care of kids of every
age and this is why she will be a great
mother and she will have kids with her
boyfriend Bobby just look at how
nautical Pudding reimagined her
surprisingly she is the last loud house
sibling to have a kid because she is
only pregnant now and that's okay every
woman needs to wait the time it takes
for her to be ready to start a family it
might be your first child but we think
that Laurie would like to have a big
family it would be too quiet in the
house otherwise don't you think that it
would make a good sequel for the loud
house we would certainly be watching it
who is your favorite character on the
loud house don't be shy to tell us who
it is in the comment section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for 10 loud house characters
reimagined as parents for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10 loud
house characters as body builders thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]